live from the headquarters of Ramsey
solutions it's the Dave Ramsey show
where that is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice I'm Dave
Ramsey your host you jump in our phone
number is triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you haven't heard
we are celebrating our 25th anniversary
of the Dave Ramsey show all summer long
and the way we're doing that is
periodically we will take a segment or
two from the show and just stop and
remember walk down memory lane a little
bit and tell some funny stories and
reminisce some of you have been with us
that long some of you have listened to
us in Nashville all the way back to
there but in so we've had some guests on
from back in the old days and so forth
and we thought it would be fun
particularly the whole team thought it
would be fun to have the one and only
Laura Johnson join us for a couple
segments Laura is celebrating her 18th
anniversary with our firm today with our
team today and welcome Laura yes hi this
is weird to be on this side of the glass
you've never been I've never been on the
air and that's probably strategic on
your part do you want to get on a
microphone nobody wants to give me a
microphone James has his hand over the
dump but at any moment is ready to go
right now what it is it's a surreal
thing it is isn't it from as many hours
as you say on the other side of the
glass from me to be sitting there in the
studio with the microphone told people
how to act in this room this is which
respect now I'm totally clueless I'm
probably screwing up everything you know
but you could tell a lot of people I've
been here over the year do it line them
up and you know when we first started
the show the very first studio that we
built we've told this ordering this
these 25-year reminiscence we just took
two rooms in an office building that
were drywall they weren't any more
soundproof than fly the moon and there
were almost basically closets they were
tiny little rooms exposed or something
like that fact
setting Blake's lap yeah we've seen very
little room and yeah we took one room
put a little round table in it that we
got it's tables for back in the scratch
and dent corner one of those press board
tables with form icon drilled holes in
and stuck the microphone stands in that
and that was mine and then you guys we
kind of put up a piece of plexiglass
between the two but it really wasn't
soundproof and you guys were shoulder
you are shoulders yes there are three of
us in the room barely could stand in
there or sit in there and Blake of
course is running the board and
producing and to start with it was just
you and him right and then later we
added another engineer in there right
Brian Brian cursors markers joined us
and but the first thing that happened
was of course we hired you and you had
been in the youth group at the church
yes as a teenager and Sharon and I as
young adults were working with the youth
right and there's two or three people on
our staff here that's true were in that
youth group yes back in the day 30 years
ago type of a thing
25 years ago right and this no it was
more than 25 years ago it's 30 years ago
and so no no I wouldn't be true because
you're only 40 I'm 40 yet it would be 25
years ago for you to be a teenager yeah
all right so anyway we're working with
the youth group and you've graduates and
I think one of the other people said hey
Lauren is looking for a job and so well
don't Hampton how'd you end up getting
on well you actually taught my Sunday
School class okay twenty thirty classes
at Christchurch also and at the end of
your lesson you said hey I'm looking for
a phone screener and assistant to the
broadcast department I thought hey I
just graduated I've got a media degree
surely I can do that job and next
morning I was in your office my resume
and interview with Bill interviewed with
you and you know went to the interview
process which even back then was a
process and I remember over Ruby
Tuesday's is where we had our final
meeting and you looked at me and you
said Laura I think you're too nice to do
this job mm-hmm and I thought well he
doesn't know me very well don't know me
at all
I know you can do the assistants job
working with Bill but phone screening
can be
brutal because you have to tell people
no a lot I can't come on there 90
percent oh yeah and they get mad yes and
they call you names and you have to be
tough you got to just say no matter how
much no matter how weird you get that
matter of fact that means you're
probably more likely to not get on the
air because I get too crazy and so the
phone screener gets kind of abused and
really ends up dishing some abuse back
out a little bit you have enough and
just you know snaps what up yeah you
know hang out and I knew that I knew
what we were facing because fun
screening is it's one of the toughest
jobs in this building really to decide
who gets to go on the air and to tell
someone no kindly and then if they don't
accept that not so kindly or whatever
and stand in there and so um you know so
I didn't you know all I know use a sweet
little girl at the church and I'm
thinking you know a little church lady
is going to get eat alive over here
right these are these people these crazy
people calling on the air going to eat
this one for lunch I proved you wrong
pretty quickly yeah yeah you you weren't
as nice as I'm old enough wanting more
than them so you were like 22 years old
I was 22 and clueless
I had a broadcast degree so I knew about
him and the wires and all that stuff I
knew nothing about finances I knew
absolutely nothing about I thought a
401k was a really long race I had no
idea an IRA
I was that you know an annuity no clue
so I and I'm you know trying to
understand people's questions and put
them on the air so I had to learn all of
that really quick and be able to type in
a description of what they're calling
about let's just talk about my spelling
over the years it's been horrible so I'm
the worst speller ever poor David had to
interpret never had a phone screener
that was like a world-class speller ever
including now yeah we're calling Delhi
out it's not one of the prerequisites to
be a phone screen or you have to be
tough you have to be insightful uff
discernment Ali the decide who gets on
the air but spelling not so much and we
can let that pass yeah and you're doing
it real fast too and your all's defense
it's done real bad or screening and
talking to people constantly and you
have you have about a four or five word
description is all you can put down for
me to figure this out but we've had
some fun and spellings come up over the
years now it's not like we all start
laughing so hard we can't talk cause
some of this spelled ridiculously or you
turned a perfectly clean call into
something pornographic or something it's
just it's it's hilarious it won't happen
it can happen no that could happen so 18
years what has changed oh my goodness
it was everything I mean number one just
the studio's we've been in we've been in
three different studios since I've been
here and it's been we've all we've done
it all with cash we've done it we've all
gotten a little bit bigger and now we're
in this nice studio and we're about to
move you know we had the groundbreaking
this morning for all it for the building
we're about to have you in another
studio so you know that those have all
changed and the video channel and I've
got a team of guys that are across the
street putting all of this on YouTube
that's been fun I mean even though the
radio industry has changed over 18 years
and how we are perceived how we are
taken I mean I remember back in the day
going to conventions and you know in
2001 and people had no clue we were
didn't really care who we were and now
we've kind of made a name for ourselves
after 25 years yeah a couple of Hall of
Fame's and other things a few of them
are noticing that we're around now it's
interesting 587 stations 25 years on the
air Laura Johnson is with us the
original phone screener then becoming
the first associate producer now
produces all of the video channel which
is the YouTube stream and other things
that we do around here has a whole team
doing that and that was a promotion when
we launched that a few years ago more on
this walk down memory lane in the next
segment
hey this is Ellen Holcomb saying
congratulations to Dave Ramsey for 25
years of celebrating freedom on the air
we're all big Ellie Holcomb fans around
here and we like our music - there you
go just like that
she's quite a lady and she and Rachel
have been friends for years and just
sharp young gal ah Laura Johnson joining
us this half-hour the original very
first phone screen er the interesting
thing is I've only ever had two and you
know that's something that we hadn't
talked about that we used to say and I
don't know if we've ever said this over
the air but we've said it behind the
scenes the radio business talk radio is
so full of egos behind the scenes and on
the air both that the number of times
that a producer and phone screener and
hosts have stayed together more than
just a couple of years is very unusual
right and we work and we are convinced
that one of the things that created the
success of this show was you me and
Blake right were you know in this you
know usually won't you two on that side
for 14 years all of us three together
shelf everyday for you all today yes I
mean we could literally look at each
other through this and even we know what
each other were thinking exactly
I mean body language we could just go
kind of a little bit you know back in
the day when you know mm or whatever
we're after every show we would sit down
and debrief and not and we did that for
a couple years and we didn't have to do
it anymore because we all knew yeah we
knew exactly what was right what was
wrong with the show what was screwed up
right what was going to call work this
one did this is how you should handle it
you know that kind of thing exactly and
you could have said this and have been
funny or you could gone there why didn't
you ask them about this you missed that
you guys coaching me you're hearing
things there and you know and it helps
you pick out which callers get on the
air which makes good radio compelling
talk radio but I'm convinced that on all
of us having big enough he goes to fight
but small enough he goes to change and
grow and work together and stayed
together 14 years is one of the reasons
we succeeded past other shows because I
think the other shows the instant people
don't put enough value on the stability
of the team that's true and it was never
really about us I mean you talk about
ego we didn't really have it was about
our listeners and in helping them and
helping people that was just a bigger
mission so really our egos weren't even
an issue for us yeah very cool good yeah
it's exactly right I mean the whole
thing was to get better because we
wanted to you know be more being more
efficient and helping people get better
ratings and you know create something
you know you have to have something here
that's entertaining and fun and you have
to have something that's poignant at
times and you have to you have to go
with those flows and you look for those
moments like train to me and how he
trained me he said the calls or the
records like the DJ plays so I'm pretty
much the DJ putting the records cueing
them out playing bad music notation
playing bad records you can't play
b-side everything exactly that's not the
kind of you know nobody listens to
b-side everything right you had you know
educate people entertain people and keep
them listening and coming back exactly
yeah choosing those calls and that
sounds kind of manipulative when we say
you know you know the caller's or the
records we play but we have to be
selective and careful because we put
like six 401k questions in a row you
know nobody's gonna listen and you know
one occasionally as an educational thing
or one that's got a funny twist or a
weird twist to it that has an
entertainment value to it that remix and
you get education and that out of the
call right that's the calls we're
looking for and you know we put the
occasional crazy one on there
entertaining right well glad ya mad
disagreed with you and y'all could get
you know have an argument I'll be great
you know it never happens anymore no
nobody's gonna mess anymore but we used
to have the whole life agents call okay
they get so mad at a car dealer a call
or two about me running car leashes down
and with some good fates on the air
about that but
pretty much people figure out that's a
losing proposition and that's kind of
going that parts gone away but wait
that's okay you doesn't have to be
combative probably my favorite call you
lost it I think we've played it before
is a guy that wanted to buy the payphone
oh we didn't do it the other day yeah
you laughed
I've never seen you laugh that hard ever
and you like all the way through the
brick to the break through the break and
it was and we all couldn't we could not
we couldn't get those yeah because it is
ridiculous yeah life is absolutely crazy
this fun stuff but I think that
stability thing you know people are
asking business all the time you know
what what do you have to do to succeed
what you have to do to succeed and I
don't know that we sat down I know we
didn't sit down and say oh we all have
to stick together for a decade and then
it'll gel at a level nobody else gels
because everybody else turns over all
the time we didn't say that it was how
it happened because we all had a bigger
mission than our own little ego and
we're big enough he goes to push through
but we had our home you know a mission
that was bigger than I was helping
people and it caused us to do that but
you know looking back on it now and
brand stability I mean you know when we
can stay on the same radio station in
the same timeslot for a long period of
time you know it goes deep into that
market we end up with this brand
penetration and how much fun is it
working with late Thompson I mean I have
have had so much fun working with him
anyway you know so working with him over
the years has been great he is a really
quick witted for those of you don't know
very funny and creative as crud they
really is and so you know we struck gold
with both of you and didn't even know
what we were hiring for it's just that
that tells us God God orchestrated it
when we look back on it and so I'm very
fun stuff yeah it did make a big
difference it really did and so yeah he
would go to those radio conventions in
the early days is a little bit like
during the headlights yes very much so
because I really wasn't into the
business side of things and a lot of
that was going on with his convention so
I was a little bit over my head or in
the early days and and we weren't really
known so it wasn't like people were
dying to talk to us yeah
as we're pushing our way understand cord
lis into conversations we didn't belong
anything to be noticed Jeff I remember
we were those people yes getting blank
getting the bellman to give him a list
of all the people that were there for
the convention and then we would slide
our own stuff under their doors and
you're really supposed to pay for that
stuff yeah I heard that way that way
yeah really I think kind of they kind of
got over it too
yeah they did well we paid them a lot of
money yeah we've all gained ourselves
too we never we never thought about that
as stealing but I guess it actually was
so we've gone back and paid them a lot
and those different conventions over
there as a matter of fact a couple of
those things over the years went broke
and we actually were the underwriting
that brought them back some of those
organizations when things got really bad
in oh seven oh eight oh yeah we came
alongside several of the movers and
shakers in the industry and said okay
we're going to we're going to just kind
of take this over and write checks and
then you can have it back once you get
back up on your feet because we felt
like the radio industry needed some of
those things right it's fun to see the
conventions now because we own
everything our names on all the posters
all the marketing that we do is great
yeah it's a completely different world
that's a big thing that's changed for
sure now the thing that has changed is
email oh yeah and that's right I'm sorry
do I really have that yeah we don't
exist with a fax machine yes we just
think when I came we had just gotten rid
of the fax machine oh really okay 99 was
when I came in to faxes kind of
going-away email was just kind of new
and we were trying to spell it no no and
yeah cell phones the old phones were all
they were they were really bad back then
they had analog now everything's digital
we had analog and the call would drop or
sounded like someone was in a 55-gallon
drum right or they're driving down the
interstate with their head stuck out the
window while trying to talk to you like
Emily their windows are down the top is
down on the car I don't know what a few
people sounds like they're in a wind
tunnel
we're like pull over to the side of the
road yeah we're going to just hang up
you know we're not going to try to talk
to you and we got to wear for a while if
it was a cell phone we just hang up
right we didn't take it we couldn't
because it was just an unreliable call
right
as we got them on the air it sounded
like garbage a few of them are that way
now you know people are doing now the
cell phones they don't talk into them oh
yes I've heard you several times on the
air say something like that yeah they
just try to hold it out here and wave it
around and look at it it's a smartphone
app yeah thing in my hand and it's there
it sounds like their voice is coming and
going all it is is they just don't talk
directly into the phone so the little
microphone doesn't pick up mr. gagal
it's a struggle yeah Holly the struggle
is real for you Holly has to Kyle has to
train them how to be a caller that's
right what happens Laura I'm proud of
you probably did 114 years awesome Laura
Johnson the original phone screener and
Associate Producer the Dave Ramsey show
now produces all of the video Channel
and a bunch of other video that happens
around here all the YouTube stuff check
it all out this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]